قلق كبير جديد الليلة حول
مستقبل أفغانستان
وطالبان شجعه الانسحاب الأمريكي
كبير المراسلين الدوليين لـ
CNN كلاريسا
وارد في كابول حيث هز انفجار قوي
مدينة كلاريسا
وولف ، كان ذلك قبل الساعة 8 مساءً بقليل عندما هز ذلك
الانفجار بصوت عال
المدينة في الواقع.  ركضنا
إلى السطح حتى سمعنا إطلاق نار متقطع ،
وسمعنا صوت صفارات الإنذار ، ثم وقع
انفجاران أصغر
حتى الآن ، ولم يتقدم أحد ليعلن
مسؤوليته عن الهجوم ، لكننا
نعلم
أنه حدث في حي يعيش فيه
وزير الدفاع الأفغاني بالنيابة
نحن '  أخبرنا أنه لم يكن في المنزل في
ذلك الوقت أنه
لم يصب بأذى ، ومنذ ذلك الانفجار
، كان من غير العادي أن نسمع
ذئابًا في جميع أنحاء هذه المدينة قد
خرجوا إلى شرفاتهم وكانوا
يرددون مرارًا وتكرارًا ،
الله أكبر يعني  الله أعظم
يفعلون ذلك الهتاف
دعما لقوات الأمن الأفغانية
وبشكل أساسي في
تحد لهذا الهجوم  ك في العاصمة ، كل
هذا يحدث كما تعلم
الذئب بينما يواصل طالبان هجومًا كبيرًا
يكتسب الزخم والأرض في جميع أنحاء
البلاد